hello and welcome to the fourth PHP
tutorial in this tutorial we're going to
be talking a little bit on comments
variables and just a little bit on like
string concatenation as it's called but
mostly how do you put variables with on
into a string basically so with that
let's hop right on into it the first
thing is commenting there's two ways to
comment then you can do a slash slash
and that's good for a single line of
comments as you can see when you hit
Enter and you come down no longer is it
the same color and now it's going to
throw you some errors whereas it's just
a single comment let's just do echo low
we'll save that put it back to the
server pop over to our old one refresh
you see hello but you don't see the this
comment here
now if you're planning on commenting
just like a huge comment or you want to
put up like a list like sometimes in
tutorials I want to put up a whole
different like a whole bunch of examples
or defining characteristics for
something and you want it you'll just
want to be able to list things out
without doing slash slash this slash
list you know the way to do that to do a
multi-line comment is a forward slash
star and then wherever you want to end
it star forward slash in everything in
here is now classified as a comment so
we can save that and throw that back to
the server refresh and we still have
hello
so that's comments now I'm gonna go
ahead and delete that since wasting
space so the next thing is variables so
variables are defined in the following
way use dollar sign and they can start
with any kind of letter uppercase or
lowercase and then also you can start
with an underscore you can't start with
a space and you can't start with a
number so if you really wanted to start
with some sort of digit you know you can
right out to or you can do like
underscore to something like that but
yeah you just can't start with the digit
as you can see it's already getting
angry with me so that's how you to find
a variable so we're just going to
literally call this bar 1 then you use
an equal sign and you're basically it's
like an assignment operator basically
you're assigning something to this
variable and what we want to assign the
bar 1 is how are you so the way that you
can use variables at least in the echo
statement is let's say you want to do
hello how are you so you want to say
hello and then what you'll do is to put
it like something to another like to put
a variable to concatenate the variable
to the string use a period that's called
a full stop and then you can just put
the variable out now what this is going
to do is make somewhat of an ugly
addition like in Python you can use
either the plus sign or the comm on that
common just automatically add to space
and the plus sign is not whereas here in
PHP you just have the full stop so when
we refresh this and we didn't add a
semicolon I'm sure yep when we refresh
this you'll see the it's kind of jammed
together so naturally what you'll have
to be used to doing is spacing things so
hello and really you want to hear space
save that and you'll put that up to the
server and you'll refresh and now you
see hello space how are you it just
looks better and so that's how you add
variables and echo out variables
naturally as you get further into this
with you know using more HTML concepts
and stuff it becomes really useful to be
echoing out various variables so now
just to expand this just slightly
further let's say the first variable we
want to use is going to be name and
we're going to say name is Harrison and
we'll do age equals 19
and let's say you want to do you want to
echo out hello and you want to build
their name and then you want to say your
ages and then you want to bold the age
you can probably guess sort of how we
might do this or a wholly how we might
do this but just as a quick example it's
good to just kind of run through this
stuff so let's say we're going to do
this hello
and then we want to do the bold the name
Harrison but when you spit out a
variable you can't you know put unless
you put literally the strong tags in
front of the variable you could do it
that way but instead what we're going to
do is just do strong and then we're
gonna append name and then again we want
to append some more tax you'll have to
add this space obviously we already out
of the space here and then we wanted to
go ahead and close off the strong tag so
we just want to bold the name then we
wanted to say you are and then again we
want the strong tag close that off
period age period we already opened up
that parentheses early Y quotes there
and then we'll just do years for it okay
so now it should say hopefully oh we
better close off the next strong tag
close that off so now it goes hello
initiates the strong puts in the name of
Harrison space you are initiate strong
again and then says the age whatever
that is and then years old so we'll save
that put that up to the server refresh
and sure enough it builds just the name
and the age
so those are the basics of defining
variables doing comments and kind of you
know starting to work in variables and
to string tags and all of that so as
always thanks for watching and until
next time